i don't know whose idea it was
[Music]
actually i think it was i think it was
my assistant's idea
to do that
i'm gonna go sell corn
kukuruzu
on the seaside of pradonsk
[Music]
[Music]
and i'm gonna try to do it
in the russian language
[Music]
jesus
[Music]
um
i thought it'd be sort of like an
uplifting light experience
but no was it was
it was pretty heavy actually overall
[Music]
wow
[Music]
so i got out there
and i'm saying you know
yes
now
and obviously with an accent
a lot of like hardened
looks and then some people opened up and
we're into it
[Laughter]
about i don't know a half hour into it
this guy came up
and he started asking me questions i
couldn't understand really much of what
he was saying
but he was selling fish and other things
and it was um
well i was stepping on his turf
obviously so there's definitely um
some sort of mafia that controls that
that beach
and what's being sold and
you know i'm sure they're taking a cut
of it so i was in there
and that definitely wasn't cool i
thought i was getting into an oh [ __ ]
uh type of experience
and then he called i guess his boss
and his boss um
i mean i couldn't understand
so much and then uh valerie got the
phone on the phone with him
and sort of cooled the situation down
[Music]
[Music]
and they granted me like two hours on
the beach to sell corn and then i had to
beat it never come back
so i made sure my corn was gone within
two hours
[Music]
it's definitely uh definitely an
experience and i'll definitely um
look back on this one day and be like
wow that was that was very interesting
[Music]
i'll never sell corn again on the beach
in berdansk or probably anywhere
but definitely not here
kanye
[Music]